子供の頃のトラウマと言ったら
小学校の時、鉄を自分で削って作った手裏剣を
こうやって……本当のヤバいやつを、
木に、こうやって、やる練習をしてたら
いとこに刺さって、お父さんに、めっちゃくちゃ怒られたことです
はじめしゃちょーです
今日、僕の家にある人が来ます
よっちです
(不穏なBGM)
なるほど
というわけで、よっちが家に来るんですけども、
ま、
もう恒例になってるんでそろそろね、
フツーのヤツをやっても、もう多分ね
本人もニヤニヤして笑っちゃうと思うんで
ちょっと今回は、ヒヤっとさせる感じで行きましょ
はいこちら、ゴルフボールです
で、今回このゴルフボールを使って何をするかといいますと、
僕んちのベランダから、外に向かって
ゴルフボールを一個ずつこうやって落としていって
変なピンポイントの場所を作るんですよ
変なピンポイントの場所に
ゴルフボールを高いところから落として
入れたら、勝ちという
ガムテープをこうやって置いといて
すごい、二階か三階かめっちゃ高いところから
こうやって落として
はいったら勝ち
という、何を競うかも全く意味不明な
ゲームをやります
(ポン)
それを使って何をしようかというと
よっちと僕がこう交互にやってく訳じゃないですか
こうやって落とす奴をね？
へっ(笑)
それはそれで面白いな(笑)
落とすとき誰かに当たるとだめなんで
お互いに場所を確認するために
落とさない人は下に降ります
で、よっちの番のときに、こう落とします、
で、落とすタイミングで僕ちょっと友達を一人
仕掛け人で車を用意させたんで
その車にゴルフボールが落ちて当たっちゃって
車に穴が開くドッキリを
しようと、思います
ブッ(笑)
というわけで今回準備したのがこちら
これ分かります？
ステッカーなんですけども、
ガラスとかに貼るとゴルフボールが
めり込んでるみたいになるんですよ
よくこんなの見つけたよ、もはや
はい、これですね
完全に、ゴルフボールがね、貼ると、出てるみたいになります
もうゴルフボールがほぼ一緒みたいなもんですね
ほぼ同じ
よっちが落とします、下に合った車のフロントガラスが
割れちゃいますぅ↑、
という感じでやっていこうと思います
ちょっと友達と打ち合わせしてちゃんと会議します
周りの人に当たったらだめだから
よっちとおいらが交互にさあ
車が来てないことを出して、
前出して、おいらがストップって言う
でも既にこれは貼ってあるから
ガラスが割れる音を出してほしいんだよ
で指示出したら、出す
おっけ、バッチリです、完璧かんぺきカンペキ
(盛り上げる音楽)
(よっち)ウｒｒｒロ、ヴァア！
(はじめ)よしやるぞやるぞ
(よっち)はい、よし
(は)はいというわけで、よっちさん
(よ)はい
(は)君は、
(は)持ってますか？
(よ)えーーっと
(よ)持ってますよ
(は)奇遇ですね
(は)僕も持ってます
(よ)……まさか
(テテテテテテテテテテテテテ)(だんだん高くなっていく音)
(チーン)(金属音)
(は)今日はですね、どっちが持ってるかっていうのを、ちょっと
(よ)はい
(は)対決しようと思いまして
(よ)わかりました
(は)やっぱ真の男っつーのはな？
(よ)あ～
(は)やっぱ決めるとこは何でもバシッと決めるわけよ
(よ)まあそうですね、確かに
(は)ゴルフボールを使って
(よ)おっ
(よ)あーよいしょ(笑)
(は)あああああああ(叫び)なんかけｇｒわｓ
(は)で何をするかといいますと
(よ)はい
(は)上から、　(よ)はい
(は)こうやって落として、(よ)はい
(は)目を落として
(よ)はい
(は)先に入れた人が勝ちというゲームをしようと思います
(よ)なるほどぉ、
(は)この意味不明な企画に、彼が放った一言は
(は)これである
(は)どっちが持っているｋｒ男かってｒｒｎを
(は)決めたいｒ思ｒまｓ
(よ)よｒろしｋｎねげいしまｓ
(二人ともロレツが回っってない)
(は)先に入れた方が勝ち……
(よ)まかしてください、もうぼく野球部ですよ？
(よ)何の部活だ(笑)
(は)ベランダからこう落とすっていう……
(よ)なるほど
(は)では……
(は)やっていきましょう！
(は)はいではやっていこうと思います
(は)よっちーまずは俺だぞ？
(よ)おっけです
(は)さん…に…いち…
(ポスッ)（やわらかいところに落ちる音）
(よ)あー惜しい
(は)見ていい？
(よ)いいですよ
(は)はいっ…えっマジで惜しくね？
(よ)素晴らしい
(は)えっえっえっえっ、マジ？　俺多分、これ、行けるわ
(ヘーッブシ(くしゃみと咳の間の音))
(よ)次は……僕の番です
(よ)スリー…ツー…ワン…
(よ)ゴー
(は)うー怖っ
(よ)見ます……はいっ
(よ)あ全然ダメ、！
(よ)全然ダメやんｗｗｗｗ
(は)スリー、トゥー、ワン、
(よ)あっ
(は)えっ
(は)見ます！　せーのっ…はい！
(よ)おしーい
(は)え、どこどこどこどこ
(よ)ここです、ここ
(は)え、やばくね！？　結構、
(よ)やばいっすｗｗ
(は)え、時間の問題じゃん、結構
(よ)時間の問題です結構
(は)え、行ける、いける、俺はいける
(ボス戦っぽいBGM)
(カーー（和風な気合の入った音）)
(音楽が止む、風の雑音だけ)
(よ)いっすかー？
(BGM再開)
(よ)オッケーっすよ
(よ)スリー…ツー…ワン…
(よ)ふぁいやっ
(パリィィイィン(ガラスが割れる音))
(よ)え？
(シリアスなBGM)
(仕掛け人)ちょｗちょっと来てみｗｗｗ
(よ)やべーじゃん
(シリアスなBGM)
(は)ちょっと
(よ)あ、OKっす
(は)いや、やばいよこれは
(は)さすがに
(シリアスなBGM、続き)
(音楽が止む)
(は)～～～～ｗｗ（笑いをこらえて鼻が鳴る）
(デデン)
(二人)ははははは(静かな笑い)
(よ)ねえこれ……
(は)いや、今回は、
(は)これが悪い
(は)今回はこれが悪いｗｗｗｗ
(いつものエンディング)
(は)一瞬でもびっくりした？
(よ)いやビックリしますよ
(よ)だって見てないっスから
(は)あそっか、そだねｗｗｗ
(よ)一回見ていいっすかーつって、確認したかったんすよ、こうやって
(よ)ほんとになってるかなーって
(よ)あーやっちゃったなーって思いました
(は)結構ビビったの？
(よ)えビビりましたよ（笑）
(は)はははははｗｗｗ
(よ)ビビるでしょそりゃ
(よ)どこ行ったかわかんないっすから
(は)いやー、あれねー
(は)近距離で見るとマジでわかるんだけど
(よ)あー
(は)上から見るとマジでわかんなくなる
(よ)あーわかんないっす
(は)というわけで今回のドッキリは、
(は)よっちが、車のフロントガラスを割るドッキリでした
(よ)はい
(は)はい
(よ)今思ったら、そんな簡単に割れないんですよね。フロントガラスって
(カツン(メガネにゴルフボールが当たる音))
(よ)いっ